that move is so ridiculous only a bot
would play that a human would never play
the move Queen to D5 because that move
would be totally risky and
counter-intuitive a computer that will
sacrifice a queen something that
traditionally humans don't do because
they're risk averse but since Levy's
opponent is using AI to cheat it's all
part of a trap that leads to Checkmate
guys playing like Magnus Carlson on
Adderall in the wake of the recent chess
cheating scandal wired ass top chess
YouTuber Levy Rosman the question how on
Earth do you actually cheat at chess and
how can you actually spot a chess
cheater if I had to describe cheating in
chess in one sentence it would be the
act of receiving external assistance
most often in the form of a chess
computer to tell you all the best moves
in the game that you're playing during
the more than 25 years since deep blue
beat Gary Kasparov aihs engines have
evolved to be way better than humans at
the Royal game I once lost to a
treadmill at a hotel because the chess
computer they programmed was so good
good top chess engines like Houdini
revenge or stockfish can run on an
iPhone if you let stockfish the best
chess computer in the world analyze a
game from start to finish we can trust
it to say what the best moves are
throughout the game far more accurately
than any human could ever come up with
so basically all chess cheaters today
are somehow accessing an AI analysis
board during a game and therefore know
all the best moves to make in each
position but how can you tell if someone
is cheating in person at a chess
tournament I've played hundreds of Chess
tournaments in my life I've only been
suspicious of a handful of players and
generally it's a mix of a few things you
have an opponent that seems extremely
distracted maybe a little bit too
jittery looking around a lot or leaving
the board when it's their move with all
eyes on them how do cheaters access an
analysis board one of the most common
methods to do this is to go to the
bathroom but our cheater has left a cell
phone somewhere hidden in the stall and
during their game they will go input
same exact moves of the game that they
are playing into that smartphone and the
smartphone will tell them the answer
then they will go back to the game and
repeat this process multiple times until
they win in 2019 Latvian Grandmaster
eager Rouses was caught red-handed on
the toilet studying an iPhone he had
secretly stashed behind a bathroom tile
but there are other examples of cheaters
that use accomplices to relay the best
moves to them most elite chess
tournaments have a board called a dgt
where every single piece is connected to
a magnetic field and every time a move
is made let's say like this the board
itself is connected to a computer so
that move will now register on the dgt
and go out to a live broadcast so in
this scenario one of the spectators
miles away in the comfort of home is
accomplice number one who plugs the game
into their engine and sends a text with
one to three characters to someone at
the tournament in fact that's what
happened in 2010 first there was 20 year
old Sebastian Feller playing the game
then there was the person watching the
game and and using the computer there
was also a middleman that middleman
would stand in the tournament Hall in a
certain location depending on what the
person watching the game would say the
middleman might go stand in the
northwest corner of the room or the left
side of the stage depending on the
suggestions he was being relayed they
basically had a pre-programmed Compass
of the room where one side meant one
thing and maybe a certain position meant
what Square what piece and so on but
what if Spectators aren't allowed at a
tournament a chess player could
theoretically bring a vibrating device
in their shoe under their arm attached
to their chest into the playing hall now
some tournaments have metal detectors
and scanners but if you walk in through
an airport style metal detector in a
chess tournament playing Hall there
isn't a guarantee that it'll pick up on
a small transmittable device that you're
hiding under your armpit in 2013
borislav Ivanov was disqualified under
the suspicion of using a device in his
shoe that received vibrations either in
Morse code or some sort of coded
sequence but what about other vibrating
devices one of the biggest memes to hit
the internet as it pertains to chess
over the last few weeks has been anal
beads it became a copy pasta on Reddit
then Elon Musk retweeted it and it got
way too big to the point that people
actually think it happened now
theoretically if we are talking about a
device that can relay chess moves to you
by vibration I'm sure if it can go into
your shoe it can go into other places
but I don't think that's what was
happening in this case but what if
you're using a simple board not a DTG
board and the game is not being streamed
or simulcast anywhere online well some
folks have shown up to games with little
watches that have a camera inside of
them so they hover the camera over the
board but they still need to have
somebody relaying the moves into their
ear or maybe some sort of other device
well those people might have tried to
wear an earpiece which is another common
method especially one that you can dig
deep into your ear canal sounds like
cheating over the board at a tournament
is hard and rare but cheating in chess
online is rampant and the first place to
spot a cheater say on chess.com is by
studying their online profile they look
at the age of the account a lot of
cheaters have an account that's maybe a
couple of weeks or a month old so here's
a profile with a couple of red flags
already it was created 48 hours ago so
the biggest red flag in my eyes is the
win rate most people win about 45 to 55
percent of the games that they play I
myself win about 60 percent of my games
so if someone's winning 75 80 90
something's not right the next red flag
is that cheaters have a high accuracy
score a metric calculated by the website
you're playing on that compares your
play to the best chess computer
I'm looking at an account right now that
was made literally yesterday got to play
only six games but because the average
accuracy of their game was 97 98 99 93
95 of 96 even the best chess players in
the world can't do that consistently
another red flag is that a suspected
cheater might be beating players with a
higher ELO score a metric from 100 to
3000 or so used to determine your
ranking in chess like if they're rating
or their ELO is 1000 they're just
clobbering people who are 2 000 might
have been playing the game for decades
how many rating points have they gained
over the last seven days oh wow they've
gained 900 oh that seems a little bit
suspicious that's just really not how
people grow at the game when Levy
suspects someone's cheating online he'll
watch them play a game turning on his
own local chess engine which will
evaluate the current position and tell
him what the best moves are when you
watch someone who you suspect of
cheating they will most likely make
moves that match that first and second
line sometimes the third line as well of
your local chess computer it doesn't
matter what engine they use and what
engine you use 95 of the time the moves
will match up another giveaway sign that
somebody is cheating while they play a
game is the fact that they take a
consistent amount of time on every
single move you might say Well they're
just thinking about their moves but no
it always falls into a range let's say a
person makes their move between five and
eight seconds every single time that's
strange why because if you think about
it that is the process of watching the
move happen on the board relaying it to
an analysis board seeing what that
computer tells you and then coming back
and where this looks really funny is
when cheaters don't realize that they
have one legal move let's say their King
is in danger they're in a check they can
just block the check they have no other
option but they don't know that because
they don't know how to play chess but
apart from these red flags is it
possible to tell if someone is cheating
from the unusual or bot-like moves they
make sometimes the dumbest move in a
position is actually the top computer
move
[Music]
some moves are human moves and some
moves are AI moves I would consider a
move not human and something that only a
bot would play if it breaks principles
of Chess entirely they will sacrifice
upon a knight a bishop a rook a queen
something that traditionally humans
don't do because they're risk-averse
computers will because they do see the
future better than any human and they
don't have any emotions a computer just
finds the best plans the best
Grandmasters in the world only evaluate
the position about two or three moves in
but the computer finds that final Act
and I can show you exactly what I'm
talking about so take this position for
example here a cheater was playing with
the white pieces a human here might
Retreat the queen a computer instead
finds this move Knight to G5 check if
the queen goes to either of these two
squares the queen will get captured here
white plays the move Queen to D5 yes you
can take the queen but if you take the
queen it's basically Checkmate because
these two Bishops link laser beam the
king in the corner so here the cheater
with white sacrificed a night to lead
the attack forward once again and then
white sacrificed a queen for basically
nothing white gave away a queen for one
pawn and that led to the devastation of
the black king white sacrificed multiple
pieces to even get to this point with no
guarantee of victory at all
but when you're in AI the victory is
guaranteed because you have seen the
future to that extent that was an
example of a sacrifice that to a human
mind felt like a mistake a seemingly
counter-intuitive idea but not to a
chess computer running tons of outcomes
and finding a way to get the king no
human in history has ever played a
sequence of moves like that so why do
people cheat at chess people cheat in
chess for a variety of different reasons
obviously if there's prizes involved
that's extremely incentivizing when
you're sitting in the comfort of your
own home and it's just you and a screen
it's much more impersonal and the cloak
of anonymity makes people empowered to
sometimes do bad things you might
literally be playing a chess Prodigy
from halfway across the world who
nobody's ever heard of
the chance of that happening is very
very unlikely